for America today every guys sitting at
home [ __ ] looking at a window peeking
waiting for the [ __ ] to get me dude
there's a thousand men at home waiting
right now to get me [ __ ] food every
day a new guy gets [ __ ] called out
for something like that what's this
gonna be like in five years nobody's
gonna be able to even ask for a [ __ ]
piece will stab let me give you a little
buckle ooh
I think there's gonna come a time and I
don't think it's gonna be very long
within ten years where we're gonna be
able to read each other's minds I think
we're gonna be able to communicate in a
different way and I think it's just
gonna be step one into some sort of a
technological world where we all read
each other's minds we can connect
together and some almost like telepathic
web way the way you use this is
obviously just an idea but I think that
if technology continues to give us
closer and closer access to people we're
gonna lose all boundaries between what a
person is and you're gonna know
everything about everyone's past and
everyone's gonna know everything about
yours and it's going to be like some
unlimited library of the mind you can
you can travel through anyone's mind and
read anyone's thoughts and as a hundred
years goes by and the technology gets
better and a thousand years go by we're
gonna integrate we're gonna figure out a
way whether it's in our grandchildren's
lifetimes or their grandchildren's
lifetimes and I think that cultural
shifts and things that are happening in
the news and people waking up to things
that they think are horrible and people
trying to correct the misdeeds of the
past all of that is us waking up in the
middle of our culture and trying to
figure out what's right figure out
what's that the healthy way to move
forward figure it balance this thing out
slow down what are we doing we're waking
up as grown adults trying to figure out
our system and there's some in justices
those in justices have to be corrected
or at least recognized we have to
understand what's the difference between
normal male-female interaction and what
sexual harassment what when is it when
someone doesn't want you to do it when
does it become a crime
you know when you don't want your
daughter to ever experience that and I
don't want anybody that's a woman to
experience real sexual harassment it's
the worst [ __ ] thing that could
probably ever happen to you because you
can't do anything physically about it
other than rape or being beaten up or
murdered it's a creepy place to be in
I've had guys hit on me before
yeah wrote a guy hit on you before were
you like wait where is this go I was
like 13 in the [ __ ] car
I also acknowledged it and never [ __ ]
happened again and I would go to gay
penis when I was a kid like we thought
it was a joke to go to a [ __ ] porn
theater on a Sunday a little porn on a
Sunday like we'd see your stupid friends
and go to the bathroom and there's
always a guy that gets next to you in
the store when you go pee he looks at
you dick and he smiles come on guys yeah
I bumped into a lot of cream you've been
out here first of all I tell you what
bothers me about the current situation
how I went off that this [ __ ] place
here has always been a [ __ ] haven for
sexual harassment this [ __ ]
neighborhood down the corner here
Hollywood is with sexual harassment got
invest and invented
did you ever see all the stuff about
Fatty Arbuckle I heard piece about fatty
rubber but I don't need to know about
fatty I know about a chick named Marilyn
Monroe then they passed around so they
killed I know but a guy named Liberace
we used to suck your dick and [ __ ]
clean you out and then send you and the
[ __ ] cold and worse it would you know
the plastic surgery so you look like
like you look like him look is one of
the most intense things a person's ever
made a person to let me tell you
something let me tell you something else
too let's welcome the elephants in the
room the [ __ ] will we hang out was
known for calmly [ __ ] hell of den of
sucking dick to a lot of years the
commies door a lot of dick sucker went
down the [ __ ] commie store I don't
know how long Harvey Weinstein has been
around but there's a song by the Eagles
and 1988 was released on the [ __ ]
long run their last out and it's called
the king of Hollywood on the way home
put it on listen to it the car you're
gonna crash your car called the king of
[ __ ] Hollywood healing ahold of [ __ ]
were they talking about
afternoon well I'm gonna hit just brace
it down it would be a shame to see all
that talent go to waste you know what
are you willing to sacrifice
wouldn't you really be just nice oh you
got look at this [ __ ] come sit down here
beside me honey let's have a little
heart-to-heart that's the [ __ ] lyrics
to this song Wow
king of Hollywood 1980 nobody knew now
look at me and tell me darlin how badly
do you want this part
yeah what's listen you put men in
positions of power and hiring women like
that and that that crazy position of
what you're trying to cast something and
you got a hundred people that want it so
bad and you're you know you're some
creepy dude some people actually think
that this would change their life if I
came to you at the end yeah thanks would
you do it how much think how much do I
get in how long do I have to suck them
for this is like it's gonna be over
pretty quick this is a career changer if
I'm a dude just do that right oh the
king of Hollywood this was Clark Gable a
boozy gay man it was based off of a book
apparently all this stuff that was in
there but he was he alleged to be a gay
man was this no but there was also a
book released in Hollywood in 1997 or a
cold you'll never work in this town
again
oh so those lyrics were about Clark
Gable yo I'm sorry I thought yes yeah
yeah but then there was a book released
in the nineteen ninety seven or eight in
this Hollywood called you'll never work
in this town again
and there was about a chick who
described all her sexual relationships
with a bunch of people in town and she
had to describe [ __ ] Don Henley the
drummer from the Eagles to guy that
sings and he would get hookers to come
up to the house wouldn't even talk to me
well don't even bend over so he would
sit on the couch where'd you hear this
this book will never work in this town
again Jesus Christ said he would [ __ ]
you never eat lunch in this town again
oh you never eat lunch and he would take
the thing do a line of coke get up and
walk up to one of them a little bit see
pump it twice and then going I'll be
back in five minutes go sit down put his
feet up do another line and he would do
that for eight hours just get up [ __ ]
one for five minutes and sit back down
before he'd come so he would never crack
a nut and he would just keep snorting to
keep a hard-on alive [ __ ] fish so who
the [ __ ] knows
listen you know it's like they all threw
the party under the bus but these
animals have been doing this since Jesus
love Chicago